the protagonist of the movie is tarus
Teddy Pietro psychowski a renowned
polish boxing champion who is currently
imprisoned at the newly established
Auschwitz concentration camp in the
opening scene Teddy has shown standing
in a line closing his eyes and
reminiscing about his past when he used
to spend his days practicing boxing in
his backyard it is revealed that one
fateful day some German soldiers
forcefully invaded his home and brought
him to this concentration camp within
the confines of the camp teddy as well
as the other prisoners endure horrendous
treatment compelled to engage in
laborious work throughout the day in
return they aren't given a proper place
to sleep and are crammed into a single
room moreover they just receive a watery
soup as their meal which is clearly not
enough for them to work for the whole
day as a result of this torture the
prisoner's contract deadly diseases and
pass away one by one even teenagers
aren't exempt from this treatment among
them is a 15 year old boy named Yannick
who is often bullied by his fellow
inmates during one work day an elderly
man gathers some fellow prisoners into
tells them about his plan to escape from
the Concentration Camp unfortunately a
guard overhears their conversation Sally
approaches the elderly man from behind
and violently strikes him on the head
with a heavy Rod resulting in his demise
as frightens everyone present there but
it appears that they are used to such
barbaric acts later that day Yannick
approaches Teddy and recognizes him as
the best boxer from Warsaw the young boy
then reveals that he is a big fan of
Teddy recalling how he used to watch his
boxing performances on television
however Teddy cautions Yannick against
discussing their identities as this
concentration camp shows no regard for
anyone's individuality the next day
Teddy is assigned to work at the
residence of a German general seizing
this opportunity he discreetly stuffed
some apples inside his clothes
afterwards he shares an apple with
Yannick who selflessly offers it to an
elderly man witnessing this act of
kindness Teddy passes another Apple
tonic urging him to eat it himself
suddenly a group of German soldiers
Having learned about the stolen apples
storm in and arrest Teddy Yannick and
the old man they are taken to an
execution site where the soldiers carry
out ruthless punishment upon those who
defy their orders at first the old man
is instructed to place an apple on top
of his head however instead of shooting
at the Apple the soldier takes aim at
the old man's head and tragically shoots
him to death the Apple still hits the
ground and Isaac Newton is still right
after this Teddy is also asked to
position the apple on his own head but
the latter refuses and opts to eat it
instead surprisingly Teddy's display of
Courage impresses the soldiers so they
decide to spare his life however they
seize Yannick and subject him to a
brutal punishment right in front of
Teddy's eyes this pains are protagonist
a lot but he cannot do anything about it
that night Teddy who is still
overwhelmed by the guilt regrets
involving the young boy in all of this
which makes him unable to sleep
meanwhile a heart-wrenching scene
unfolds as a large group of Jewish
people including little kids are herded
into a gas chamber a soldier then pours
lethal gas into the chamber mercilessly
snuffing at the lives of all those
inside as days passed the prisoner's
situation grows increasingly difficult
as they are forced to commence their
brutal labor Before Sunrise with even
less food than before one day a soldier
tosses a piece of food onto the ground
triggering A desperate struggle among
the starving prisoners to acquire it the
soldier seems to enjoy this scene so he
devises a new plan he orders two
prisoners to engage in a contest of
slapping promising that the winner will
receive an additional piece of food
after the first round Teddy is drawn
into the competition using his skills as
a boxing champion he easily Dodges his
opponent's attacks and lands the winning
blow Dana White then appears and says I
think I can make some money off of this
shortly after a German officer who
happens to be a boxer as well arrives at
the scene and challenges Teddy to a
First Blood match the latter agrees
right away and so the match begins from
the very start the officer launches
Relentless attacks against Teddy but our
hero skillfully evades every blow and
when the opportunity arises he delivers
a powerful punch to the officer's face
securing Victory impressed by Teddy's
technique and fearlessness the German
officer respects his skill and rewards
him with a substantial piece of bread
Teddy then returns to his fellow
prisoners and shares the food with them
as everyone is happily eating Teddy
notices that Yannick is suffering from a
persistent cough and cold due to the
lack of proper food and rest the illness
gradually worsens escalating into a
fever that eventually develops into
pneumonia deeply concerned for the boy's
well-being Petty approaches the same
German officer the following morning
pleading for some food and Medicine the
officer agrees to help but stipulates
that Teddy must comply with his
condition following this the officer
escorts Teddy to his superiors and tells
them about his exceptional boxing skills
recognizing the absence of any form of
entertainment within the camp the
officer proposes organizing a boxing
match where Teddy would face off against
other Fighters initially the superiors
expressed skepticism doubting whether
the skinny Teddy can endure even a
minute in the ring however the officer
manages to persuade his superiors
convincing them to give it a try the
scene then cuts to the first boxing
match within the camp where Teddy is
assigned to face another skilled boxer
as the match begins Teddy finds himself
self-cornered by his opponent in the
first round however he makes a strong
comeback in the second round delivering
a series of powerful punches that
ultimately leads him to Victory this
achievement not only impresses the
German superiors but also the son of the
German general Rudy who is among among
Spectators as a reward Teddy is provided
with extra food and water he is also
promoted to work in the horse stable
where he is assured with more food later
that night Teddy visits the Camp's
infirmary to have his wounds treated
Upon finishing his treatment he
approaches the nurse and requests
medicine for pneumonia unlike the camp
guards the nurse appears to be kind so
she gives Teddy a bunch of different
medications after this Teddy heads to
the sick Ward where numerous workers are
in critical condition he administers
pneumonia medicine to Yannick and hands
the remaining medication to a health
care worker present there now employed
at the horse stable Teddy finds himself
with more Leisure Time which he utilizes
to practice boxing after a few weeks
Yannick finally recovers and Teddy
arranges for him to work at the
infirmary there the young boy meets a
beautiful girl named halcya and the two
quickly become friends over time Teddy
gains a good shape due to improved food
and rest yannick's situation also
improves but the rest are prisoners
still suffering in the same way they are
subjected to inhumane treatment just
like animals and Jewish people are
cruelly executed on a daily basis
moreover over the lack of proper
medication and Care in the sick Ward
leads to a lot of deaths because of this
Teddy makes every effort to assist his
fellow prisoners he emerges victorious
in all the matches he has placed in and
shares his rewarded food with his fellow
inmates in addition he secretly
transports vital medicines from the
infirmary to the sick ward in order to
provide some relief to the suffering
inmates one day German soldiers summon a
formidable opponent from another prison
to face Teddy hoping to see a new Victor
however Teddy's exceptional agility and
boxing skill proves to be dominant over
the big guy ultimately securing him the
victory as a result Teddy appears to be
rewarded with a more generous portion of
food which he selflessly shares with his
fellow inmates as he has done before
call him Teddy Rosevelt because this
dude is smooth in the next scene Rudy
Falls ill and the doctor reveals that he
is typhoid sadly the young boy passes
away because of the disease leaving the
general devastated the following morning
Teddy observes lifeless bodies being
carried outside the camp gate to his
dismay the dead bodies turn out to be of
those who Teddy defeated in the boxing
match overwhelmed by guilt he decides to
no longer participate in any more fights
however when Yannick gets to know of
this he urges Teddy to keep going saying
that he is the prisoner's only hope that
same night as usual a group of Jewish
people are ordered to form a line and
enter the gas chamber this time the
group includes halcya who had been
caught stealing food one of the soldiers
holds her at gunpoint demanding she
remove her clothing unexpectedly the
girl seizes The Soldier's gun and shoots
him instead in a retaliatory response
the remaining soldiers opened fire
tragically killing Elsia amidst the
chaos other innocent prisoners also fall
victim to the gunfire ionak Witnesses
the horrifying incident from a distance
and is devastated by the loss of Elsia
later it is revealed that the German
general has also sustained a gunshot
wound to his hand due to which she has
taken to the infirmary there he learns
that Yannick was assigned to work in the
infirmary without proper authorization
as a result the general takes ionic into
custody and subjects him to torturous
treatment when Teddy learns of this the
following day he approaches the higher
ranking officials and pleads for the
release of the young boy however the
officials deny his request determined to
secure ionic's Freedom Teddy proposes a
deal he offers to face the best German
boxer hammershlag in exchange for
yannick's release Teddy further
stipulates that if the officials reject
the deal he will stop participating in
any further matches after a bit of
deliberation the officials decide to
accept the deal however they have a plan
in mind so that Teddy doesn't win the
match the fight takes place in the
evening and both the opponents get ready
as the match starts Teddy struggles to
counter The Barrage of attacks thrown by
Homer schlag in the first round he is
easily overpowered by his adversary
however in the second round Teddy
manages to land some significant punches
on homerschlag witnessing their top box
or being beaten the officials discreetly
signal the referee to announce a round
break the officials then make Teddy
drink a mysterious liquid before
starting the third round this unknown
drink soon shows its effect causing
Teddy's Vision to get blurred and making
him feel dizzy turns out homerschlager
is even more potent than Goldschlager
exploiting this Advantage hammerschlag
delivers a powerful blow that knocks
Teddy to the ground with this the German
officials declare their boxers the
winner concluding the match instantly
shortly after Teddy regains his footing
and requests to continue fighting in
response the soldiers bring forth a
brutally injured Yannick and toss him in
front of Teddy the higher ranking
officials then command Teddy to fight
against the boy or else face the threat
of ionic being shot and killed our hero
hesitates for a while as he doesn't want
to harm his best friend any further
unfortunately because of this slight
deliberation one of the soldiers
ruthlessly shoots yonek and kills him on
the spot Teddy is also tied to a pole
and hanged there for a whole night this
is the first story I've read since
coming back from vacation these Vibes
suck the following morning a soldier
releases Teddy from his restraints and
instructs him to get back to work
however he instead makes his way to the
area where the deceased bodies are being
cremated with a heavy heart Teddy
searches for yannick's room but only
manages to find a toy that belonged to
him clutching it Teddy Mourns for a
while but then gathers his resolve and
makes a courageous vow to defeat
hammerschlag with Newfound determination
he then enters the boxing ring where
hammershlag is fighting other prisoners
to everyone's astonishment Teddy
challenges the big guy to a duel and the
latter promptly accepts notably a guest
in the audience is revealed to be the
warden of another prison who recognizes
Teddy from their encounter in Warsaw
confident in Teddy's abilities the
warden places a bet in his favor the
match commences and initially Teddy
deliberately endures a barrage of
punches from his opponent without
retaliating his face becomes stained
with blood yet he maintains a smile but
when he gets the perfect chance Teddy
counter attacks with a couple of solid
punches that knocks the best German
boxer to the ground ultimately securing
it Victory the prisoners in the audience
erupt with cheers hailing Teddy is the
champion of the Auschwitz Camp impressed
by his prowess the warden of the other
prison approaches the general and asks
teddies transfer to their facility as a
result is freed from the Auschwitz Camp
the very next day and transferred to
another prison in a post-credits scene
it is revealed that Teddy continued to
fight another concentration camps years
later he is ultimately liberated by the
Allied Forces after returning to his
hometown Teddy starts training young
children in the sport of boxing
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching